[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in the NBA commissioner Adam
Silver last time you're on I thought we
solved a lot of problems with the NBA I
still have some things that maybe we
could solve but we'll talk about those
uh coming up we had Jeff Van Gundy on
yesterday he said let's do away with
half time
uh offensive goaltending and maybe free
throws
do you want to respond to any of those
things that Jeff Van Gundy one of your
voices of your sport
I actually listened to that interview
with with Jeff and I think even he
acknowledged he was having fun
um you know it's interesting on halftime
when we've looked to shorten it a bit
because we I think you know we changed
the format of the last two minutes A
couple of years ago to Speed the game
along and I think we forget sometimes
that the guys really do need the break I
mean put aside the programming at
halftime the commercials but it maybe
you could shorten it slightly but I
think it is Meaningful to the players in
addition to the coaching that goes on at
halftime the opportunity to get a
breather you know it's by the way I
remember you know Rob thornwell Rod who
used to work at the league office with
me telling me that when he was a player
that was an opportunity to have a smoke
and a cup of coffee
what do you think about offensive
goaltending that we do away with once
it's on the rim it's it's European style
right the fever rule that's what we do
in the Olympics and in the the
basketball World Cup I I think it's it's
an exciting play you know we've looked
at it we've experimented with it
um you know in fact we have a
competition committee meeting this
afternoon and uh it's come up over time
it I think around some of the uh
Olympics it's been there's been a more
serious conversation about it but for
whatever reason people haven't been
talking about it a lot lately what about
the All-Star game uh you talked about
this yesterday maybe the international
Stars against the American stars is is
that uh something that could happen as
early as next year it it not as early as
next year we're going to be in
Indianapolis one of the things we're
looking at for next year is returning to
the east first West format the more
traditional format I mean we definitely
need to do something I mean to to
Spruce it up a bit it's uh you know I
think all the leagues have dealt with
issues around All-Star I know when when
I was a kid when you turn in to an
All-Star game it was an opportunity to
see players you never otherwise saw
you know and literally to see them next
to each other in their uniforms because
I grew up in New York you you know I was
a big baseball fan you just didn't see
players that often you know from from
other teams I think now with League Pass
digital media they're so familiar to
players that
um it's there's just something lacking
and I think we need to find a way to
create some real competition and again
an idea that's come up in the past doing
you know the Ryder Cup style except not
just us versus Europe U.S versus the
world and one of the reasons we hadn't
done that historically was there's an
imbalance because even as the number of
international players grow it's still
far less than than half but I think to
me as as we look to make it more
engaging for fans that shouldn't be the
sole reason we don't do it I think we
could add additional All-Stars there's
something we could do if and that's one
of the things we're going to talk about
today because again we do need to do
something to make it more interesting
I was wondering about this I brought it
up with Jeff Van Gundy where we see
flopping and what if it was called and
the punishment was you got the letter F
on your jersey and and you you know it's
like the scarlet letter and the scarlet
letter is f for flopping like a buckeye
for Ohio State football
yeah you know that the issue one of the
uh the serious things we're discussing
is possibly adding a technical for
flapping which they do in international
basketball college added a a flopping
technical just this past season of
course the issue one of the reasons we
haven't done it historically is because
by definition they're fooling the
referees and we had an after the game
remedy which was a fine but frankly if
you're successful in fooling the
referees a relatively small fine isn't
going to make a difference you may even
be celebrated for having done it so I I
think we do need putting aside The
Scarlet Letter we I I'm in favor of
adding a technical because even though
it'll be a difficult call there is
replay on certain places you might catch
it after the fact and I think there has
to be a greater disincentive for doing
it and that and there has to be a
competitive risk to flopping
as the commissioner how much influence
do you have over your TV partners
you know you got the Joker who now
people are seeing they're almost forced
to see him because he's in the NBA
Finals but to Market some of these
players you know Joker's a hard guy to
Market he's not a highlight guy but what
influence can you have over the TV
partners of let's can we focus in on
some of these other players that maybe
you know the rest of the country doesn't
focus on you know how quickly you forget
when you were at SportsCenter calls from
me when I was running MBA entertainment
why are you running more highlights
they're still in the blank so
we've we have some influence it's
interesting I mean to
the networks I mean they do focus on the
teams and players that they think are
going to be most popular
um In fairness to them the Joker hasn't
been in the finals before of course he's
a two-time MVP but we're seeing now I
think I read the other day he went from
the 18th most popular player on social
media to the number one player on social
media over the last two weeks so fans
are responding the networks will respond
I I mean I've been at the the first
three finals games I mean it's it's an
incredible
you know display of basketball I know
you know you're a former player a huge
fan you know and I and I think the
country is warming up to it I mean the
team style that that they play Miami too
for that matter I mean this is just from
a from a basketball Aficionado
standpoint this is this is really you
know basketball playing at its highest
level and I think and and the by the way
we're seeing it in the ratings I think
you know going in the projections were
that we were going to be down almost 25
from Austin and San Francisco and of
course that hasn't been the case in fact
you know probably after last night we're
going to be up a little bit which is
says a lot about the league that you
have two mid-sized markets of course you
know a popular team in Miami
um a nuggets team that has never been in
the finals and the fans are responding
by watching yeah they're two likable
teams we're talking to the commissioner
of the NBA Adam Silver what was your
reaction to the uh live tour PGA Tour
news
you know I I don't know enough from
about what really went on there on the
inside I guess I'm not so surprised
given that there was a lawsuit ongoing
lawsuit and investigation and the fact
that they were
I think hurting the golfers at the end
of the day I mean they were turning
golfers against each other again this is
just me from a Fan's perspective and a
fan of the sport I'd all say that
because golf just like basketball is
extremely Global
um there's there's interest around the
world I think that you know I was
listening to some of the prior comments
on your show and I I hear what people
are saying about Saudi Arabia on the
other hand and this is for you know good
and bad that when
the Saudis invest in sports it gets
outside's attention now I don't want to
complain about that because we want to
get outside attention on the other hand
somebody could go down the list there
they are investors in some of our
largest American corporations
um some of the most well-known brands
have investments from them and I also
think it's a it's a two-edged sword I I
hear the comments about Sport washing on
the other hand
um you're talking about it others are
talking about it it's not as if some
Aaron golfer can say one thing about
his reaction to Saudi Arabia investing
in golf and that's left at that I think
people are pretty sophisticated and the
same way
um the World Cup the football World Cup
soccer World Cup brought enormous
attention to Qatar I think people learn
about these countries learn about what's
happening in the world and other in ways
they otherwise wouldn't so I think the
media does its job
um but but at the end of the day
I also think and now talking
specifically about the MBA where we're
such a global sport I I think people are
a little too dismissive these days about
the benefits that come from the
commonality around sports that with a
sport like basketball or our finals are
distributed virtually everywhere in the
world the sport is played everywhere in
the world it's an opportunity to bring
people together I mean look at we're
talking about you know jokic from you
know a Serbia you know we we have over
25 percent of our players now we're born
outside of the United States I I just
think that there it's the media does its
job but it has South have the Saudis
look to invest or buy an NBA team no
they certainly haven't come to the
league office and under our rules
um an individual can only buy an NBA
team right now you can
um a fund and that's what's happening
here
it's called a sovereign wealth fund
that's investing in the in the PGA Tour
but we allow funds to invest in teams
but not control teams not to have
influence over a team so to to own an
NBA team there has to be an individual
with a certain percent of the team to
control it
is the John Morant investigation over
we're just waiting for the finals to be
over to announce the decision
the latter we are waiting for the finals
to be over
um I'm aware of course of these reports
on social media about you know whether
the gun was in fact a gun uh and so we
haven't completely wrapped it up does
that matter commissioner if that's a toy
gun
you know it's interesting it's the very
issue is
for a job certainly in the first
incident was treating a gun as a toy
and that's what we're talking about and
that's what I think the danger is to
society taking a gun live streaming it
you know without getting into gun issues
in terms of the propriety of owning guns
and the use of guns I think everyone
agrees that gun safety is critically
important and that guns aren't toys so
it's it's something that I'm thinking a
lot about because again I'm not going to
get into the specifics of the
investigation but in fact if you are
live streaming something that to the
world looks exactly like a gun and and
in a frankly Reckless manner should it
matter whether or not it's a real gun I
mean I you know I I will say at the end
of the day in terms of doing my job
everything that's presented to us is
relevant past conduct is relevant
um since the circumstances in which
you're you're doing whatever the ACT is
becomes relevant and in this case you
know obviously we're going to take into
account whatever's presented to us
when we heard from you after what
happened with jaw this second time
around it's almost like there was
disappointment like you were let down by
John Moran is that a fair assessment
it is and and Joe Dumars who now runs
basketball operations to the league and
I talked a lot about it because we were
both in the meeting with him
um they had the Players Association
Tamika tremelio was in the meeting with
us and just honestly my sense was he was
very sincere in how contrite he was in
how serious he was taking the issue
again now talking about the first
incident where
there's no fact in dispute he was
holding a gun you know inebriated in a
club waving it live streaming it so that
no that's the that's the first go-round
and I I no job a bit I I had known him
he's a star in our league and since was
he came in he fully owned it was saying
I made a terrible mistake
um learned from the mistake and so then
to get the report and then to see online
that in fact
he was then live streaming
a gun certainly looks like a gun a Glock
you know in a kind of Reckless manner
sure you know I was incredibly
disappointed
what would be a big suspension
I'm not going to get into precise number
of games but um I I will only say in
response to people who say
eight wasn't enough the first time
around
it felt like a pretty severe punishment
at the time and an eight-game suspension
of course without pay
um and so I I will say you know I and I
said this before
in terms of impacting his behavior
with 12 games have made a difference the
first time 15 games I really don't know
I also the older I get I I realized that
I can't control other people and that he
has to own his own conduct and
regardless of the number of games he had
been suspended for first time around he
owns this not me and he has to take
responsibility for it and part of this
you know it's it's fine for somebody to
come in and take response responsibility
for their action and I'll even give him
the benefit of the doubt that he was
sincere he's now made this mistake again
and I think one of the things we even
talked about then is nobody's naive in
the league office certainly not Joe
Dumars been at this a long time was
you know we'll see you're as you go back
out into the world how you choose to
comport yourself and and so now here we
are again
um dealing with an issue around jaw and
I I also think it's important to point
out that if this is not about just
discipline and then we'll just cross our
fingers and then hope there's not a
third time
I recognize that he needs
um some assistance you know from the
league office his Union uh his team
um
he's no doubt he's a remarkable player
and and I think he's a very engaging
young man it's one of the reasons he has
this enormous following on social media
but it's a two-edged sword and he has to
own that and take responsibility for it
and my hope is that wherever we come out
in terms of discipline that there's a uh
an acceptance that we need to find ways
to engage with each other going forward
to to so he can change the trajectory
he's now on which is not a positive one
and I wondered about that commissioner
that I was worried about him over the
summer now we've had this second
incident and also if you suspend
somebody for 20 or 30 or 40 games what
happens to that person when they have
all that free time
and you could be adding to the the issue
with John Moran not subtracting yeah
precisely and I'm worried about that too
and so again
putting aside the number of games that
um we may be looking at
I'd like to come up with a program and
frankly working with him
um in which there is a a joint sense a
mutual commitment that
um we need to put together a program
um not something that's you know a
couple of sessions and I'm back
but but something that um where he will
be able to use time away from the game
look he's suspended right now I mean
he's away he I mean it's the off season
but he's suspended from Team activities
and and and there I want to find a way
where frankly you know he's not being
kicked to the curb but basketball will
take a back seat
and first and foremost we're going to
focus on him as a Young Man developing
as as a better person as someone who's
more responsible particularly when it
comes to guns I mean this is a really
serious issue
all right next time you're on we got it
once again I got to address carrying
okay just
we got we have to address this and maybe
you could bring it up maybe just you and
me we just sit down and we discuss get
get everybody I don't need a committee
what do you think
we did talk about this last time well I
know I know I know it's an issue it's
it's um I hear you it's it it's a hard
call and uh
I hear it from fans when I'm in I'm in
the stands and next time why don't I
come on with Joe Dumars my our
basketball expert and let's talk about
it because I I you know in all
seriousness I you know we are the most
played team sport in America
and so people can relate to it when they
watch the game and they and they what
you know whether it's you know carrying
palming traveling whatever it is people
have a sense and one thing that
frustrates me in terms of the rules that
and as I said I got a competition
committee meeting this afternoon that
when it's explained to me by the
officials and Monty McCutchen who who
oversees our officiating staff it
quickly becomes very technical and I
think we need to find a way with our
rules that they can be presented in a
simple way and while everything can't be
so bright line but there's a better
sense like yes that's traveling or no
it's not and and and and
that's something I I think we can we
should be able to do a better job did
you just invite me to the committee I
mean I unless because it's a yes if you
want me involved in this I'd be more
than happy
so yes all right there you go that's
official is there like a handshake or a
jacket or Blazer that I wear an ID card
whatever I need to be on that committee
you let me know
I will I will by the way I was so I when
I was in Denver the other day and you
know traveling jumping time zones and
things it was late at night I was just
flipping around the television and I
watched Blended what'd you think
I thought it was a pretty good movie I
you know I know you've done a bunch of
those Adam Sandler movies I hadn't seen
it before it's a few years old but uh I
enjoyed it I'm an actor who does sports
radio on the side commissioner
but you didn't play yourself you you
know I think in Hustle you played Dan
Patrick yeah you didn't and Blended by
the way I'm an Aficionado of your films
I thank you thank you and the fact that
you call them films and not movies I I
respect that as well and you know who
carries the ball more than anybody
absolutely commissioner absolutely you
know what I'm going to get Sandler to do
a PSA for the NBA on an anti-carrying
program
thank you it could have a double meaning
by the way yeah the John Morant
anti-carrying absolutely I got it
commissioner hey I know you got a busy
day thank you for uh taking time thanks
Dan that's Adam Silver NBA commissioner
it's a good appearance by the
commissioner wow
it was on a t I didn't think he was
gonna go there I'm like that was great
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw it out there
and I carrying